- I just want to notify
everyone in advance that
I will be calling it a vagina
bag, because in the UK,
fanny means vagina.
(upbeat music)
- My name's Alicia, and
I'm a fanny pack guru.
So if you're trying fanny
packs out for the first time,
the best advice I can
give you is to just exude
confidence with it.
There's no inappropriate
moment for a fanny
if you have the right look going on.
Fanny packs for life.
(upbeat music)
- I would prefer if
fanny packs were a thing
that were like socially acceptable.
- I actually wore a
fanny pack to Disneyland
the last time I went,
and that was actually the
most amazing experience ever,
because it was just so freeing!
- My shoulders always hurt
from carrying a purse around.
- One of my friends is coming
into town this weekend,
so I'm going to go to a fancy dinner
in a fanny pack for sure.
- I'm afraid that it's not going to match
with all my clothes.
- I'm really worried about what people are
going to say or think,
because it means you're
looking at my crotch.
(upbeat music)
- I like these sunglasses.
I'm going to make mine look like an emoji.
Like an emoji exploded all over.
- This is actually quite well themed.
Mine's a bit erratic.
- Yes!
- Simple, and I like the back.
- It's a bit coordinated by accident.
It looks like NASA/someone
that likes drugs.
- I got America all over my fanny.
(upbeat music)
- So my first experience
was temperamental,
because every time I walked,
it bounced and made its
way around to the front,
even when I didn't require it to.
- Ok so I'm moving today,
and my friend Amber is
going to come help me.
I am wearing my fanny pack.
And she just knocked, so let's go.
- A fanny pack?
(laughing)
I like it.
- Would you wear one?
- Yeah, I have one!
- It is not the most fashionable,
and I already look nuts,
so I feel like it just makes it worse.
- It's making me realize
how much I care about
other people's validation
with what I'm wearing.
- We're at Griffith Park
right now, we're on a hike.
This is the reason why fanny packs exist,
because I have never felt so comfortable.
- Today I'm going to try and buy a car
with my fanny pack on.
I don't think they're
going to take me seriously.
- I've been validating the
experience to other people
by saying it's an experiment.
- I haven't gotten any
questions about it today.
But it's more annoying than I expected.
The novelty has worn off.
(techno music)
- I loved wearing a fanny pack.
It was super convenient,
it was really easy,
the only part was it
looked terrible with almost
every outfit.
- This thing is too small.
It's like I can barely fit anything in it.
- I was starting to fashion my outfits
around the fanny pack.
You just have to wear like sporty clothes.
- You either look like
a small child or a mom.
So today I've gone with the
forty-year-old mother look.
And I'm neither of those things.
But I felt I had to dress that way.
- I wasn't putting my purse
on the ground all the time.
Not sure how I feel peeing with this on.
I guess it's better than
putting a purse on the ground.
- If you care what people think about you,
I wouldn't wear a fanny pack.
(upbeat music)